it was a kind of very last minute
casting my manager got a call checking
on my my availability for it and he and
he called me and he said I got a call
about this movie it's the Barbie movie
Greta grow was directing it and it's
filming in London for you know four
months or something so I told them you
probably wouldn't want to do it because
you probably don't want to go to London
and I was like what
do you mean call them back I mean he
didn't like like blow it or anything but
he's like I managed their expectations
that you might not want to do and I was
like how can I not do it it's like I
need to do it so I somehow got Greta's
email address I think through a common
friend of ours and I emailed her I was
like can I be can I do that part and she
was like let's get on a zoom right now
here's here's a zoom link I'll be on
there for the next hour
so she was just hanging out on the zoom
she's like just click that link whenever
you're ready and then we talked about it
and it just all happened really fast
from there hi Barbie
oh hi Alan there are no multiples of
Alan he's just Alan yeah
confused about that